trying to
find a hopeful path way out
so one is the current coronavirus
pandemic
or in particular not the virus but
our handling of it is there something
philosophically politically that
you would like to see that you would
like to recommend that you would like
to maybe give a hopeful message if we
take that kind of trajectory we might be
able to get out
because i'm kind of worried about the
economic pain that people are feeling
that there's this quiet
suffering i mean i agree with you
completely there is a quite suffering
it's horrible
i mean i know people you know i go to a
lot of restaurants
one of the things we love to do is eat
out my wife
doesn't like cooking anymore we don't
have kid we don't have kids in the house
anymore so she doesn't have to so we go
out a lot we go to restaurants and
because we have our favorites so we go
to them a lot we get to know
the owners of the restaurant the chef
and it's just
heartbreaking you know these people put
their life
you know their blood sweat and tears i
mean real blood sweat and tears into
these projects
restaurants are super difficult to to
manage most of them go bankrupt anyway
and and the restaurants we go to a good
restaurant so they've done a good job
and they've they got a unique value
and they shut them down and you know
many of them will never open
you know something like this to make 50
60 restaurants in some places won't open
these are people's lives these are
people's capital these are people effort
these are people's
love talk about love they love what they
do particularly if they're the chef as
well
and it's gone and it's disappeared and
what are they going to do with their
lives now they're going to live off the
government the way
our politicians would like them bigger
and bigger stimulus plans so we can hand
checks to people
to get them used to living off of us
rather than it's disgusting and it's
offensive and it's
unbelievably sad and this is where it
comes to this i care about other people
i mean this idea that objectivists don't
care i mean i love these people who
who provide me with pleasure of eating
wonderful
food in a great environment there's
something inspiring about them too like
when i see a great restaurant
i want to do better with my my own stuff
yeah exactly it's it's it's
inspiring anybody who does it is
excellent i love sports
because it's the one realm in which
you'd still value and celebrate
excellence
i but i try to celebrate excellence
everything in my life so i
you know i try to be nice to these
people and you know with covid we
we went more to restaurants believe it
or not and we did
more take out stuff we made an effort
particularly the restaurants we really
love to
keep them going to encourage them to
support them
the problem is the problem is philosophy
drives the world
the response to covet has been worse
than pathetic
um and it's driven by philosophy
it's driven by disrespect to science
uh ignorance and disrespect of
statistics
a disrespect of individual human
decision making
government has to decide everything for
us
and and just throughout the process in
the disrespect of markets because we
didn't let markets work to to
to facilitate what we needed in order to
deal with this fibers
if you look at the pla it's interesting
that the only place on the planet that's
done well with us are parts of asia
right taiwan did phenomenally with this
and the vice president of taiwan is a
epidemiologist so he knew what he was
doing
and they got it right from the beginning
south korea did
did amazing even hong kong and singapore
it's
you know hong kong is just very few
deaths
an economy wasn't shut down in any of
those places
there were no lockdowns in any of those
places
the cdc had plans before this happened
and how to deal with good plans indeed
if you
ask people around the world before the
pandemic which country is
best prepared for pandemic they would
have said the united states
because of the cdc's plans and how all
of our emergency reserves and all that
and the wealth
and yet all of that went out the window
because people
panicked people didn't think
go back to reason people were arrogant
uh
refused to to to use the tools that they
had at their disposal to deal with this
so you deal with pandemics it's very
simple how you deal with pandemics and
this is how south korea and taiwan and
you deal with them by not by testing
tracing and isolating that's it and you
do it well
and you do it vigorously and you do it
on scale if you have to
and you scale up to do it we have the
wealth to do that
you